one of our rewards here's on patreon
whatever video you request you must
definitely do and put up on the youtubes
nine point nine times out of ten it is a
video reaction every once in a while
someone like a Rosa par will come along
and ask us to do it but today Eric
Oliver great beautiful handsome man in
San Francisco
this guy is an OG mofo works and wiki
fandom this guy he is a huge nerd and he
exudes glee I love you Eric Oliver I
know you got our thank you letter and I
know you got your t-shirt you slept and
sent us a photo of you wearing it
maybe this shirt take off the whole
bottom half send a full body shot cuz
that's what we deserve hmm he wants to
watch Black Panthers coming to America
oh boy it's it's the end of Black
Panther that's the ending scene where
he's talking yeah in Oakland Funny or
Die douche
I have yet to experience what the
outside world has to offer
[Music]
just once I myself feels like it could
be a Marvel booth
[Music]
yes
to Eddie Murphy is you know I appreciate
about that you know how there's been
those videos of like Donald Trump as
Darth Vader or something yeah where they
superimpose audio over it that was the
only time I thought this actually didn't
work was when they were trying to take a
line that Eddie Murphy says and make it
seem like that's what black panther was
saying under the mask they get lost but
I love how they sliced it together with
all the footage of Eddie Murphy he's
like smiling because oh yeah you're
taking Eddie Murphy from coming to
America you're not trying to like see
how this footage sliced together it
could be you just like Black Panther you
know they're not doing that they're just
taking Eddie Murphy and putting him in
here and I said it feels like a Marvel
movie because like if Black Panther had
more humor lighthearted character this
is one more comedic Marvel joints then
yeah it would have probably been a lot
like this yeah and I feel like that was
the thing that kind of drove this home
for me because I'm kind of spoiled at
this point by you know people like Aldo
Jones and and all those people who are
being cut and like CGI of places so just
cutting back and forth to like one shot
from coming to America one shot from
Black Panther it doesn't a hundred
percent coalesce that way but I thought
yeah all the choices of moments yeah
really good the choices when you
actually see Eddie Murphy yeah I get one
time I thought didn't work was when he's
in the mask and they're trying to take
lines and make it look like that's what
Black Panthers saying no one they just
committed to know this is Eddie Murphy
as Black Panther yeah yes it's fortunate
that in the early parts of coming to
America you have this big like palace
area with these you know different
servants and things during an accent
yeah yeah so it's like that stuff really
matches pretty well yeah and the accent
too it's good that was a cute video
thanks Erik Oliver you know with all
your wiki fandom and all the heavy
requests you have I like that you chose
something light for us he saw a black
panel for you guys sound like it hadn't
seen many times Anthea wrong
six
times no he bought every ticket for
every screening in town yeah Derek the
Eric show the Eric show ma'am
Eric Oliver we love you buddy hope
you're happy and don't worry one day we
will come and I will visit you but it
didn't work you guys can subscribe to
reject land poorly bark we'll talk to
you later bye bye YouTube by E by E
[Music]